Demi what also is going on with you
about extraterrestrial life I don't
believe there's anything out there I
don't know it's just I can't fathom that
we're the only life in the universe have
you met aliens personally no I haven't
you consider the word alien offensive to
extraterrestrials okay here's about that
it's in this video
oh my God she's being so sensitive and I
was like no it's just that's what I was
told you are a very sensitive woman
because you're worried about how the
extraterrestrials are feeling about
being called aliens I call them alien
all right so this is just a belief do
you believe the government is hiding
evidence from us yes I haven't seen
aliens per se but I've seen UFOs I've
seen many UFOs what did you see and
where were you so what I do is I will
actually meditate and then go
Transcendental Meditation no this is
like with the intention of seeing UFOs
oh okay so you meditate for like 30
minutes and then you open your eyes and
you are you want to do it someplace of a
higher frequency
so like the desert so you meditate you
open your eyes and you look up and for
my birthday one year I was like guys I
really want to do this like I was with a
group of friends I was like can we all
meditate like I know it sounds really
boring but I want to do this but you
really do have good friends because I
would have been like yeah you're crazy
whatever you want to do it's your
birthday right okay cool so we all of a
sudden it within 10 minutes we look up
in the sky and there was this huge
orb of light that just appeared out of
nowhere in the middle of the sky was
bigger than any other star in the sky
then it starts to make like this motion
movement of like a question mark in the
sky and then it gets small and then it
just backs out and I was like did y'all
see that did they see it talking about
yes everyone saw it or are they afraid
to tell you they haven't seen no they
they all saw it and then there's been
other occasions where
um a light will like appear why are
these extraterrestrials while hiding
from us why don't they come out and like
why do they have to fly around in a
question mark I don't understand why
they don't explain that to me maybe they
were being symbolic um with the question
mark I don't like it well I I think
maybe they're waiting for Humanity to
come to conclusions on their own
um rather than just like showing
themselves and freaking everybody out
because you know a lot of people would
lose their if oh I would just
appeared I'm listen I got enough trouble
with the people on this planet